salut tout le monde bienvenue dans un
nouveau podcast portrait d'un prospect
de la draft NBA 2023 on voudrait on vous
donne l'essentiel en une vingtaine de
minutes et c'est 20 minutes elles seront
consacrées à Taylor Hendrix
[Musique]
taylorrent né le 22 novembre 2003 il
jouait à yucf cette année un freshman
ucfc Central Florida 2 mètres 400
chaussures
97 kg de mètres 14 d'envergure au NBA
draft combine nous l'avons huitième sur
notre big board au moment où on parle 9e
chez ispienne et il est même sixième
pour the Ringer et the athletic pour en
parler nous avons Hugues et FD bons
souhaits
salut à toutes et à tous FD tu dis plus
bonjour alors si mais c'est juste que
j'ai pas entendu Hugues dire bonjour au
podcast précédent donc je me suis dit on
va faire un partout et voilà
[Rires]
on commence par par la biographie SD
c'est toi qui t'en occupe dis-nous
qu'est-ce qu'il y a mené Tyler Hendricks
jusqu'à yucif
le mot le plus important déjà dans sa
biographie c'est Florida Taylor
Hendricks il est originaire de Floride
il est né à forte l'auteurdale et puis
après il a pas beaucoup bougé il est
allé en pripschool juste à côté de chez
lui il a joué de là-bas avec Scotti
Brown evernon carré à son arrivée lors
de ses premières années après School
avec eux il a gagné un titre de champion
d'Etat avant de finalement transférer
vers une autre école toujours en Floride
puis de regagner ce même titre de
champion d'Etat donc il a il a tout
doucement gagné en autorité lors de ces
dernières années au lycée il s'est très
vite installé comme une comme une recrue
4 étoiles et puis c'est très logiquement
qui a été recruté par UCF et qu'il a
décidé de rester en Floride au niveau du
bac40 familial on en sait on en sait
assez peu la seule info c'est que son
frère est également athlète
universitaire puisqu'il a également été
recruté la même année par yousf donc
est-ce que c'est un bénéficiaire
collatéral du succès de son frère et
donc on l'a fait pour recruter en deux
en même temps on ne sait pas je ne veux
pas donner de mauvais enfin louer de
mauvaises intentions à Youssef mais
voilà pour la biographie elle aurait
Driss qui arrive qui va peut-être pour
la première fois de sa vie quitter la
Floride natale c'est ça parce que top 10
il a attendu top 10 c'est quand même un
des joueurs entre les big boards de
début de saison et ceux de fin de saison
qui a vu le sa cote le plus augmenter
peut-être avec un
Kobe skin des gens comme ça mais lui il
est vraiment il a vraiment explosé assez
puis assez rapidement et c'est mon très
très rapidement qu'est-ce qu'il faisait
à Youcef pas mal de temps de jeu mais
qu'est-ce qu'on lui demandait de faire
c'est donc le partenaire donc dans one
to patch avec
du coup un extérieur c'est une équipe
qui était assez faible du CF ils ont ils
jouaient avec deux grands mais donc deux
pivot qui avait un très faible temps de
jeu donc globalement tu avais Taylor
Hendrix et puis les deux grands qui se
relayaient à côté c'est un joueur qui a
été majoritairement utilisé pour donner
du spacing énormément de pick and pop
c'est à dire son argument de vente
principal on va on va aller dessus juste
après et c'est un gars qui a apporté
énormément de Russell dans le dans la
défense qui s'est sur tous les ballons
qui tombaient par terre qui a été un
second rideau incroyable qui a été un
rebondeur aussi féroce qui est souvent
quitté sa position pour aller là-dessus
donc c'est pour ça aussi qu'il est qu'il
est qu'il est monté c'est d'abord pour
sa défense et par sa capacité à envoyer
des longues filoches toute la saison
malgré un comment dire un supporte une
caste très très très moyen
et est-ce qu'il y a eu une évolution
tout au long de la saison Hugues dans ce
rôle
il a eu de plus en plus de ticket shoot
au fur et à mesure de la saison on lui a
demandé d'aller un peu plus vers le
panier parce qu'il était efficace vers
le panier mais on est à 108 les up tenté
au début de l'année vraiment il était
que autour de la périphérie et on a de
plus en plus mis de jeux de Pyton roll
avec du sleeproll mais toujours en
deuxième attention on a été assez
frustré
toute la saison pour pour telle sur ce
secteur là et il a eu le droit de jouer
avec pas mal de fautes
avait pas le luxe de pouvoir pouvoir
avoir une rotation très compliquée donc
on l'a plusieurs fois vu jouer avec
trois fautes en première mi-temps ça
montrait la confiance qu'elle avait dans
son coach et la nécessité qui soit sur
le terrain pour que l'équipe ait une
chance de remporter quelques matchs
FD quel est quel est son
produit d'appel pour la NBA pourquoi on
le va le drafter donc pourquoi on
imagine le poser sur un terrain un jour
une combinaison de tir et de défense
pour sa taille sans vouloir donner un
label de friendy mais c'est vraiment ça
c'est avec sa taille il a un tir qui est
extrêmement fluide qui a été extrêmement
efficace au cours de l'année c'est 40%
de ses tirs cette année sont pris à
trois points pour 40% de réussite donc
avec un volume qui est quand même
important et une très bonne réussite
c'est essentiellement du spot-up comme
l'a dit Hux soit sur du pick-up soit en
laissant le garde play de Florida enfin
de yucif se développer en attendant et
en enchaînant les filoches il a il a des
mécaniques très très fluides ils
profitent de sa taille pour tirer
parfois au dessus du Clos out parce
qu'il a une mécanique qui reste
légèrement légèrement du côté long du
spectre mais voilà ça c'est pour le tir
et puis
de l'autre côté un potentiel défensif
notamment au ballon avec du SL avec de
la lecture de jeu et avec des contre
spectaculaires ça te donne un profil
avec sa taille qui est qui a les champs
pour les équipes bien qui est
potentiellement recherché ce fameux
protecteur de cercle plus
écarteur de jeux
offensif qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qu'il
peut qu'est-ce qu'il peut améliorer dans
son profil
Hugues pour pour vraiment pour vraiment
passer un cap et atteindre ce potentiel
qu'est-ce qui a encore peut-être à
améliorer pour pour devenir ce gars qui
voilà qui qui défoncèrent les qui shoot
de loin
ça va être plus côté mental en terme
d'agressivité je pense premièrement
parce que on a vu un jour avec beaucoup
de toucher
que ce soit dans le tir extérieur ou
près du panier ou dans le dans le
flotteur game mais c'est un joueur qui a
eu des longues phases d'absence tu peux
avoir 10 15 minutes ou tu es le X ne
fait rien sur le terrain où il va pas
prendre de responsabilité c'est quelque
chose qui a pu être un peu frustrant
alors que défensivement il avait
clairement
cette intensité là on va devoir
développer la polyvalence du tiers
puisque c'est du cash and shoot c'est du
pitchen pop est-ce que telwix va pouvoir
se créer son propre tien autour de la
ligne à trois points notamment sur des
situations peut-être un peu stagnante ou
de hand of est-ce qu'il va pouvoir
sur un œuvre voilà je m'en récupérer le
ballon voir son extérieur tourner autour
de lui puis c'est rien se débloque
déclencher c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
l'a vu faire vraiment pour lui il faut
qu'il reçoive la balle et qui déclenche
directement sinon la situation il
transmet le ballon donc voilà plus de
plus de polyvalence plus d'agressivité
on croit quand même j'ai l'impression à
sa capacité à finir au panier donc
pareil au niveau de la de la pose
d'écran
développer développer ce jeu sur genre
pic and roll un peu plus mettre de
l'impact sur ses écrans et rouler et
rouler vers le cercle
fdil était en midmate genre
X et en plus pas dans une énorme fac
donc première partie saison ils ont pas
joué des adversaires non plus
extraordinaires il est capable de finir
au cercle en NBA c'est un athlète NBA
athlète NBA oui
en termes d'explosivité il l'a
maintenant en termes de finition au
Cercle c'est surtout au niveau de au
niveau de la force physique au niveau de
l'absorption des impacts qui va devoir
progresser
finir au cercle il l'a fait notamment
sur transition où il est allé exploser
quelques dunks très intéressant
maintenant pour moi le grand axe de
progression si tu veux lui donner la
balle dans les mains c'est déjà un le
dribble arrivé au Cercle ça on va
pouvoir en reparler mais une fois qui
qui se rapproche du cercle et ce qui est
capable de
d'absorber les contacts au niveau du
moment du gabber pour pouvoir être
encore équilibré au moment du au moment
de finir on a vu énormément de tirs ou
enfin énormément de
situations de Drive où il n'arrive pas à
créer le la séparation par rapport à son
défenseur et obligé de lancer un espèce
de tir drop ou quelque chose où il va
chercher la planche des tirs qui sont à
très faibles pourcentage aujourd'hui la
finition au Cercle elle est vraiment
compliquée parce qu'elle n'arrive pas à
se créer de séparation sur sur jeu 2000
enfin sur je vais placer sur deux
Mitterrand et sur le drive du coup
qu'est-ce que pour développer là dessus
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qu'il faut
travailler qu'est-ce qui lui manque
aujourd'hui
à la fois une qualité de dribble pour
faire la séparation une qualité dribble
ou bien des peut-être des fans sur le
spot-up où il est pas encore capable
même quand le défenseur sort fort sur
son tir parce qu'ils sont tirés
respectés mais d'attaquer sur le premier
pas donc c'est des appuis quasiment plus
que du dribbles quoi sur les appuis
parce que sur les jambes sur le bas du
corps il manque encore de force et donc
un petit bump le
désaxe totalement et l'empêche de
continuer vers le cercle
et puis enfin peut-être voilà il lui
manque un peu peut-être un spin ou ou un
tiers drop pour en fait voilà s'il ne
veut pas aller au contact qu'il puisse
quand même finir proche du panel on va
faire du travail
ça peut se développer et je pense que ça
va se développer et Hugues défensivement
est-ce qu'il y a des trucs à améliorer
aussi au-delà de l'agressivité donc tu
as parlé
pouvoir encaisser les au niveau des
changements de direction c'est un joueur
qui est très bon dans le second rideau
mais c'est un joueur sur pic and roll
quand il va être attaqué par des
extérieurs ils vont beaucoup lui
attaquer au niveau de son centre de
gravité donc moi j'aime bien ces appuis
mais le vraiment le niveau de la
tourneur du bassin pouvoir un peu plus
encaisser après il est encore léger
enfin tout jeune joueur donc là dessus
ça va être à développer
et puis
défensivement après il prend pas mal de
rebond mais je le trouve pas
extraordinaire au rebond non plus voilà
c'est ça on est on l'a souvent comparé
si on avait dit nous c'est un peu genre
le score de direct van derbilt avec un
tir extérieur on n'est pas sur le profil
rebondor de vente d'eau même si il y a
cette longueur là je j'ai l'impression
qu'il est très passif regarde beaucoup
le ballon et il réagit un petit peu tard
donc il va falloir être
plus safe là dessus plus sécurisant
parce qu'une équipe va essayer de
d'aller le chercher pour ça pour être
une deuxième paire intérieur c'est
flatteur 22 défensivement on est sur ce
type de profil c'est comme d'ailleurs
c'est le corps de vandeau et le tir
extérieur d'un je sais pas si tu prends
un joli
portis et pour l'instant on est quand
même très très loin du du de la cavité
de défensive de de vandeaux mais le
corps peut tendre à ça
FD dans le dans les schémas défensifs
bon on sait que les joueurs qui
défendent trois quatre sont un peu
amenés à tout faire quoi ils peuvent
défendre du porteur du ballon ils
peuvent défendre du poseur d'écran ils
peuvent être rumeurs ils peuvent être
dotés est-ce qu'il y a des situations
pour lesquelles tu étais un peu plus
inquiet que d'autres
ouais justement moi sur la sur la sur la
comparaison avec Vando au début je
pensais que c'était pas prophétique je
pensais que c'était défense je me suis
dit on s'enflamme peut-être un peu parce
que Van derbyte a quand même une vision
de jeu et justement on l'a vu dans
énormément de situations notamment à
l'université où il défendaient beaucoup
en zone
moi j'ai peut-être un petit peu plus de
de questions sur son sa qualité sur le
ballon sa qualité sur le sur le point of
attack ou peut-être que ça ces appuis
que moi je suis un petit peu moins fan
peut-être que là ça va peut-être poser
problème là où je le trouve excellent
c'est encore une fois sur sur l'aspect
hors ballon sur le rumeur où il a une
anticipation qui est folle et en fait
les gros contre sont surtout une
indication de 1 à bonne lecture de des
rotations défensives et un sens du
timing qui est vraiment vraiment très
enfin vraiment au-dessus de la moyenne
pour son âge maintenant sur le ballon
j'ai j'ai mes doutes sur des joueurs un
petit peu rapides et malheureusement on
est toujours obligé d'en parler pour
l'instant un petit peu frêle pour
encaisser les contacts sur le jeu
intérieur bien sûr mais c'est important
aussi de rappeler que ces joueurs sur
les postes intérieurs généralement
n'atteignent pas leur potentiel tout de
suite il y a plein d'exemples et même de
mecs draftés très haut
Hugues psychologiquement et ce qu'on a
autre chose à dire que que cette ce
manque d'agressivité qui peut être
psychologique mais qui peut être aussi
dû justement ce serait le physique
non j'ai pas énormément de choses j'ai
regardé un petit peu au niveau de ces
interviews tu sais avec les différentes
équipes et puis chaque fois il dit oui
je pense que je me plairais bien ici que
je peux remplir ces cases et il répond
de façon très binaire on lui dit vous
pensez que votre spacing peut apporter à
l'équipe et voilà je pense que mon
spetting peut porter l'équipe il y a le
Thunder vous pensez que vous allez
pouvoir dissuader que je pense que je
vais pouvoir dissuader donc bon
pas un enfant écran tu vois vraiment moi
je travaille en maternelle c'est les
gamins qui répètent exactement ce que tu
viens de partir juste avant donc ils
vont passer à la pression qui savent et
en fait ben juste il a il a répété et
puis sur le terrain c'est vraiment cette
ce côté très binaire genre défensivement
je me donne je me jette par terre j'ai
du jeu seul et puis offensivement quand
on compte sur moi on se cache un petit
peu après comme on le disait on projette
pas un garçon sur lequel on va compter
offensivement sur les premières années
c'est pas là-dessus qu'on le draft et
une équipe ne devrait pas se dire en
tout cas j'espère ne devrait pas se dire
je prends parce que je veux un finisseur
au panier de pitch and roll top top tout
de suite et j'ai besoin d'un attaquant
en tout cas si c'est le cas héros de
casting à mes yeux
FD justement on parle de l'année 1 là si
on se consomme juste sur l'année 1 pour
toi qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qu'il faut
lui faire faire
comme l'a dit Hugues offensivement
le jouer à fond se sentir ne lui
demandez que très très peu de
responsabilités balles en main
l'utiliser comme un flirt spacer c'est
là qui est c'est là qu'il a été
excellent en début de saison avec
Youssef c'est ça qui peut apporter en
NBA c'est ça qui va le mettre en
confiance
lui laisser le temps sur les années
2-3-4 pour développer des répétitions
mal en main développer des répétitions
sur en tant que en tant que de pick and
roller pour l'instant je pense en
spacing en apportant du spaceing dans
une équipe qui a déjà des créateurs
des créateurs avec le ballon je pense
que c'est ça le contexte qui lui ira le
mieux et puis défensivement voilà le
maître en tant qu'arromer sur des sur
des sur des courtes séquences où il va
pouvoir apporter par sa dissuasion mais
ne pas c'est pas pour moi c'est pas un
mec que tu envoies des gens en mission
défensive dès sa première année en tout
cas pas sur le ballon tu parles de
années de trois quatre pour toi le sur
la rendu contrat donc admettons années 4
c'est quoi le le meilleur scénario
possible et puis un scénario un peu plus
médian
pour moi le meilleur scénario possible
c'est un mec qui a gardé sa précision au
tir donc qui a un tireur à 30 39 40 % en
NBA qui est capable quand les défenses
sortent fort sur lui de poser un ou deux
dribbles et d'aller finir fort au panier
et qui défensivement a montré qu'il
pouvait qu'il pouvait être un défenseur
sur surpiquen roll peut-être pas
forcément en drop mais quelqu'un qui
peut être efficace au point of attack en
faisant des Edge tout en gardant cette
capacité en deuxième rideau d'aller
faire des comptes si ça ça fonctionne
pas ça restera un très très bon
défenseur hors ballon et un tireur de
bon niveau capable voilà il a quand même
des skills Ball en main des petites
passent donc ça ça va être plus que
seulement un tireur
donc ça ça reste quand même un attaquant
qui va pouvoir apporter quelque chose
j'espère dans trois quatre ans
Hugues est-ce que tu as des choses
est-ce que tu vois les choses
différemment par rapport à ces scénarios
médians et meilleur scénarios possibles
non je suis complètement d'accord avec
ça je regarde un petit peu là dans les
dans les conférences des profils qui
pourraient ressembler sur un
développement Chris bouchée qui avait
fait un peu d'année à Oregon mais dans
ce dans ce genre là alors qu'il y a du
jeu qui a dû jouer petit pivot les
macdaniel's Jaden et
jellenge dans ce dans encore une fois ce
profil là c'est des choses que j'aime
bien et qui ont mis un petit peu de
temps se développer et qui maintenant
sont des défenseurs référencés
mais ça me pose la question moi de
pourquoi est-ce qu'on l'achète aussi au
partout quoi j'ai un peu plus bas je je
comprends le profil je vois la rareté du
profil où il dit et tout mais pour moi
c'est casse gueule pour le garçon de
tête pris 6e 7e comme je peux le voir
projeter du côté de d'Indiana ou du côté
de
[Musique]
du côté de d'Orlando donc
voilà il va falloir laisser du temps
garçon et je préférerais qu'il glisse un
petit peu qui tombe dans une équipe
comme Dallas ou une équipe de ce profil
là qui lui conviendrait peut-être un peu
mieux
tu es d'accord FDA avec ça
ouais totalement pour moi Dallas en fait
quand j'ai dit une équipe où on veut
juste lui demander de faire du du spot
avec des mecs qui créent avec la balle
j'avais Luka dans chiche et qui irring
en tête pour moi voilà c'est c'est le
contexte parfait pour lui en tout cas
parfait pour pour qu'il puisse apporter
dès la première année pour son
développement personnel peut-être le
mettre dans une équipe ou justement on
va lui donner des balles enfin il faut
lui donner des répétitions avec la balle
on va le laisser faire plus de choses
mais si on veut qu'il soit efficace dès
la première année offensive bon c'est
dans ce rôle qu'il faut le qu'il faut le
mettre totalement d'accord et bien voilà
vous êtes parfaitement d'accord il y a
pas débat sur Tyler and like c'est très
bien
c'est beau c'est beau comme vous mettez
d'accord c'est beau c'est beau ou c'est
ennuyeux en fait tu peux tu peux dire
les deux on peut dire les deux mais bon
moi j'aime j'aime bien cette espèce
d'accord alors que alors que Hugues est
parfois vu comme quelqu'un avec des
positions extravagantes
en ça devient assez grave vraiment pour
faire de la SMR pour dormir c'est
parfait
finalement à peu près la même chose
de différent c'est génial c'était le
profil Express mais complet de Taylor
Hendrix joueur de yucief Candida à la
draft NBA 2023 on profite à retrouver
sur YouTube sur nos plateformes d'écoute
comme tous les autres on a plus de 20
profils publiés et il y en aura
peut-être même un peu plus de 25 au
total donc donc c'est à consulter à
consommer sans modération activer les
cloches voilà tout ce que disent les
gens qui font ce genre de vidéo on vous
embrasse suivez la draft aller sur
envergure.co et des bisous Ciao